Dutch prime minister Mark Ruta says F-16
fighter jets will be given to Ukraine as
soon as the conditions are met President
Vladimir zielinski welcomed what he is
describing as a historic decision
Ukraine has long called for warplanes
which it says are essential to counter
Russia's Air Force
this is one more step in strengthening
Ukraine's air defenses we will use F-16
Jets to keep Russian terrorists away
from Ukrainian cities and Villages Mark
and I have agreed on the number of f-16s
that will be provided to Ukraine after
our pilots and Engineers have been
trained
is editor-in-chief of the Swiss military
review he joins us from Geneva so the
ukrainians we mentioned that have been
asking for jets for a long time is this
a game changer
um it's not a game changer but it allows
Ukraine to stay in the game until now we
can say that Ukraine has received quite
a number of combat aircraft mostly
mig-29s so it has been able to maintain
the number of aircraft that it started
the war with but of course Western
countries have no more Mega 29s no more
ex-soviet airplanes to commit to this
fight and therefore it will need to be
Western airplanes from now on
what can these planes do how are
ukrainians likely to use them
these airplanes are multi-row and
because they are fitted with a very
Comprehensive electronic suite and even
the older generation f-16s that we are
talking about now have been modernized
repeatedly they are capable of air
defense they are capable of
reconnaissance including electronic uh
suppression jamming missions and of
course striking uh capabilities so air
to ground capabilities as well but what
does that actually mean in in terms of
the war I understand everything you just
said but I mean can it either help tilt
the balance of the war or are we likely
to see different headlines coming out of
this conflict as a result of this
we can imagine that the situation is
going to change in the coming weeks and
coming months because uh Russian Air
Forces have become emboldened uh by the
fact that uh less and less uh Ukrainian
aircraft were able to take to the air
and intercept and fire missiles at them
so without a sufficient number of
airplanes the Ukrainian Air Force cannot
maintain its uh its uh territorial its
uh airspace Integrity we're going to see
in the coming months more Ukrainian
airplanes and therefore this will
probably push back uh the Russian Air
Force strikes in the coming months it's
one thing to have the Jets it's another
to have the pilots to fly them and
they're not going to be you know Dutch
Pilots or european Pilots involved in
this war or not directly they're not
going to be in the cockpit flying them
who's going to fly them how long does it
take to train the Ukrainian Pilots
I can give you a shorthand sir there
have been uh 35 or so Ukrainian pilots
who have already been earmarked to
undergo training abroad on Western
airplanes it can be the F-16 but there
is also other Western airplanes that are
being considered uh for this role and so
uh the United States Air Force has
conducted a small survey a study to see
how many weeks how many months are
needed for these qualified Ukrainian
Pilots experience with mig-29s and
Sukhoi 27 how to convert them onto
Western airplanes and within three to
four months this this transformation of
the pilots is doable but of course they
will have
a specific knowledge in certain areas
certain key areas they will be able to
perform certain key missions but perhaps
not all of the missions that Western
professional Pilots would have
in Chief of the Swiss military review
thank you very much
thank you